hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the instrument through which
witches and wizards Channel their magic
I am of course talking about ones more
specifically we're going to be
discussing ones in the context of their
necessity how come some Wizards use a
wand While others seemingly don't have
the need for one to Tool and lastly and
more importantly why don't witches and
wizards use multiple ones there's Source
information in the original books which
suggests that using multiple ones is
plausible so why isn't anyone doing it
let's dive in now we know that in the
Wizarding World is a common place for
young witches and wizards to visit
ollivanders and receive their first wand
an instrument with which they are able
to begin honing and channeling their
magical abilities a wand is the object
through which a witch or wizard channels
his or her magic it is made from wood
and has a magical substance at its core
ones made by Ollivander have caused a
phoenix feather unicorn hair or
Dragonheart string and are of varying
Woods lengths and flexibilities and on
the day that they get their first
extremely personal wand their Journey
Into the Depths of the whistling World
truly begins finally able to untap and
uncover its Mysteries the importance of
one ownership in Harry Potter is
emphasized to suggest that essentially
no witch or wizard no matter how
powerful or weak is complete without
their wand the wand chooses the wizard
that much has always been clear to those
of us who have studied one law if you
are any wizard at all you will be able
to channel your magic through almost any
instrument the best results however must
always come where there is the strongest
Affinity between Wizard and wand these
connections are complex an initial
attraction and then a mutual quest for
experience the ones learning from The
Wizard the wizard from the wand and from
the day the pairing of wand in which
wizard first occurs the wand becomes
more and more a vital part of their
existence the wand and want owner
establish an almost symbiotic
relationship and part of this aspect
comes down to the fact that ones are
quasi-sentient able to independently
perform actions through their own will
okay so ones are important and the
relationship with their Caster is
important but the first thing I want to
look at here before we get to multiple
ones is are they necessary we see some
wonderless magic in Harry Potter and
it's always a bit confusing wait a
second don't you need a one to perform
that spell well here's the thing
wonderless magic only really stands out
to us because of its ubiquity Among The
Wizarding World that we have become
familiarized with through the books and
films we are indoctrinated from the
start to think that a wand is essential
to magical achievement where in reality
one less magic is actually a norm for
other species and cultures perfect
examples of magical beings that are able
to perform magic without ones include
goblins and elves whose lack of wand
usage has even prompted them to refer to
humans as wand bearers expanding on this
in the World of Harry Potter the wand is
said to be a European invention which
means that cultures outside of Europe
would have always practiced magic
without one it is said that Native
American Wizards have their own methods
of producing magic predating
colonization and that African Wizards
only adopted the wand in the 20th
century so really one less magic is a
lot more common than you may think I
think that outside of these cultures and
species the use of Oneness magic in a
world where the use of a wand is
ubiquitous can be attributed to one of
two things powerful magical ability vast
experience and calculated casting or
lack of experience and accidental
casting essentially if you're a gifted
Witcher wizard you're powerful enough to
channel magic without a wand you don't
need it however for those that have more
difficulty channeling magic or one to
cast an exceptionally powerful spell
than a wand might be a good way of
achieving this for the most part I
imagine Wizards like Dumbledore and
Voldemort don't see the need for using a
wand as their power has transcended most
others in The Wizarding World however
come time to Jewel a wand might be a lot
more important and that's likely why
Voldemort and Dumbledore heavily
leveraged their ones against one another
in their fated Jewel okay now on to
multiple ones so if ones aren't even
necessary to begin with why on Earth
would one entertain the idea of using
several at a time does it allow you to
channel magic further why does Harry use
three ones against fenra greybach in the
Deathly Hallows he leapt over an
armchair and wrestled the three ones
from draco's grip pointed them at
Grayback and yelled Stupify the werewolf
was lifted off his feet by the triple
spell flew up to the ceiling what it
sounds like from the above passage is
that Harry using several ones actually
Amplified the effects of the spell
causing Grayback to fly up to the
ceiling so is that truly the result of
several ones or would one want to have
done the trick here's what I think
Harry's spell in this instance was not
Amplified by using multiple ones okay
but if it didn't amplify the effects
then why did you use them the answer
reflex if we examine the passage closely
we can see that Harry rather
aggressively wrestled the ones from
draco's grip immediately yelling a spell
this wasn't a controlled environment
Harry didn't see three ones and think oh
that'll be triple the power he just did
whatever he could in the moment and as
it turned out Draco had three ones in
his grips okay now I'm going to dive
into reasons four how I think using
multiple ones could work in some
extremely rare cases but doesn't work
most of the time the first problem is
wand ownership as I mentioned earlier
the relationship between a wand and a
witch or wizard is highly unique and
extremely complicated it's a sort of
symbiotic Bond a one-on-one relationship
we know what happens when witches and
wizards are paired with the wrong wand
think Ron Weasley's hand-me-down wand or
Neville Longbottom's wand it just
doesn't end well these illustrate that
it's hot enough to gain the allegiance
of one wand let alone multiple so how
can we reasonably expect that a given
which or wizard could Garner the
allegiance of multiple and then
capitalize on all of them at once in a
battle scenario yes it's possible to
gain the allegiance of more ones by
besting the previous owner but it's also
a highly complicated subject and the
laws of ones are not entirely clear as
we've seen with the highly temperamental
Elder Wand don't get me wrong ones are
capable of changing Masters but it's not
so easy to win someone's one from them
usually you have to disarm stun or kill
the opposing witch or Wizard and even
then the one may not choose you it may
honor its connection with its previous
Master furthermore I can't imagine it'd
be easy to wield multiple ones how do
you even hold three things in your hand
at once like that sounds hard to aim try
holding three Chopsticks in one hand and
aiming them all the same thing it's not
easy a real world example would be
weapons sure a sword is a powerful
weapon but using two doesn't mean that
it's going to be an improvement over one
it probably just means you'll be less
effective with each and that's kind of
how I see the use of multiple ones going
for someone even with proper allegiances
established with all of these ones which
is already highly unlikely I think that
the only way that this could work is if
someone happened to have multiple ones
choose them while they were young this
would give them allegiance to multiple
ones and also give them an opportunity
to get used to multiple ones but even
then I'm not sure it would be any kind
of an advantage what do you guys think
did you ever think about this let me
know in the comment section below until
next time remember time will not slow
down when something unpleasant lies
ahead
foreign